speaking of difficult immigration cases
meghan markle meghan markle this story
has
fascinated the entire world
the interview between meghan markle and
prince harry who when
he was occasionally allowed to speak and
oprah winfrey
and some people say this is a frivolous
sort of interview it's not i think it
actually gets at the heart
of the decay of our political system
differences that we have not just
between the united states and the united
kingdom
but differences we have between the old
order the old standards of duty and
responsibility and love of country
and a new culture that's replaced it of
narcissism
and selfishness and pursuing one's
appetites
at infinitum meghan markle
explaining why she had to flee
she had to get out of there because she
you know we talked about her a little
bit yesterday
she was so overwhelmed do you know these
royals they expected her to google
the national anthem of her adopted
country
into which royal family she was marrying
you know she is shocking
they wanted her to learn some hymns
before
her massive wedding in the church of
england
which uh her family her new adopted
family
actually runs shocking awful can you
believe that kind of
burden who was she going to turn to to
teach her how to be a royal
her fiance the prince i know i don't
know that's so
that'd be outrageous how could you do
that but she goes further she's alleging
racism which is sort of the signature
crime of
of liberal modernity there no no other
crime
can even come close to the crime of
racism
which is expanding in its its definition
by the day
and even by the hour meghan markle
says that the royals did not want to
give archie
or any of her children uh the the title
prince
you know the williams kids would be
called prince and princess but not harry
and megan's kids and this was very
offensive and do you know
some unnamed members of the royal family
actually
raised questions about the skin
color or the skin tone of archie before
he would be born hear the allegations
if they can compare what the experience
that i went through was similar to
what has been shared with us kate was
called weighty katie
waiting to marry william while i imagine
that was really hard
and i do i can't picture what that felt
like
this is not the same and if a member of
his family will comfortably say we've
all had to deal with things that are
rude
rude and racist are not the same rude
and racist are not the same
this is true racism
is a type of rudeness
rudeness this kind of you know simple
word here really what she's saying is
adversity
racism is a type of adversity racism and
adversity are not the same thing
because there are many other types of
rudeness and adversity
racism is just one of them but for
markle
and for the entire left
racism race is the
defining feature of life
so you can be rich
you can be famous you can be a hollywood
starlet
you can marry a prince one of the best
known princes
left in the world you can be accepted
into the royal family
but if you are even slightly
dark if you can in any way claim
membership in a racial victim group
which meghan markle
i guess can she certainly does
then you are oppressed there was a
babylon b headline yesterday saying
meghan markle inspires millions of girls
by by showing them that no matter how
rich
and beautiful and famous you are you
still can claim to be oppressed that's
what she's doing here
and the reason that this interview
totally backfired
this was supposed to be a big pr move by
meghan markle to make herself likeable
and to vilify the
british royal family and i think it had
the opposite effect i don't think the
queen has ever been more popular in her
entire life
and i don't think meghan markle's ever
been more unpopular because she totally
misread the situation
she's so
divorced from the reality of of her
situation
she's so consumed by this frivolous
shallow ridiculous racial grievance
ideology
that she can't recognize her own immense
extraordinary privilege and more than
that
she exemplifies this tendency in
modernity
to want all the privileges and not want
any of the duty to her i mean she's
she's spelling this out in the oprah
interview she thinks oh wow gosh
being a princess is great i get to be
rich and famous and wear a tiara and
live in fancy castles
man this sounds awesome sign me up oh
wait a second i have to do things
oh i don't have the total liberty to do
whatever i want at any given time of the
day
uh yeah that doesn't sound good harry
divorce your family
do it do it or else leave all your
friends and family
or else i'm gonna do something horrible
and you better
you better listen to me that that was
the takeaway from the interview and
in markle's own perverse mind in her
warped mind
she's the victim but she's not she's not
the victim
even this this claim here that
it was a slight by the royal family that
little archie was not going to be styled
to prince
does that really hold up to scrutiny
here's her claim in those months when i
was pregnant
all around this same time
so we have in tandem the conversation of
he won't be
given security it's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what what
first of all i i don't believe this
woman as pierce morgan said uh
you know he wouldn't believe her if she
was reading him her
like the menu at breakfast in the
morning or something right something to
that effect
um so i don't i don't i'm not saying it
didn't happen i'm just saying i have
there's no reason to believe
anything that this woman says but let's
say something like this did happen
was the conversation you know
that boy you know megan because you are
slightly dark-skinned like very very
slightly
like people wouldn't pick up on it like
my sicilian mother was much darker skin
than meghan markle much much much more
so
if that boy comes out even slightly
swarthy
we have to banish everyone from the
kingdom this is a horrible do you think
it was that conversation or do you think
it was hmm i wonder who he's going to
look like
because i don't know i'm much darker
skinned
than my wife when we were discussing
what our kid would look like say oh i
wonder what it'll look like will they
have your eyes will they have your nose
will have your skin color i don't know
he actually did get my skin color
which conversation was it it seems to me
that
if the conversation were a vicious
bigoted conversation about how much
they're going to hate harry or archie
rather if he comes out
slightly dark because i guess the kid is
what he's like an eighth black or
something
that you know he that would be terrible
for the royal family don't you think
that conversation would have happened
before harry got married don't you think
that
conversation would have happened before
the royal family accepted meghan markle
before prince charles walked her down
the aisle
before the royal family bent over
backwards and did everything to welcome
this woman
did they j they just learned right right
when the kid was about to be born they
said oh my gosh
this woman is somewhat black oh my
goodness
wow we need to do something about uh no
i don't think so
i don't think that was the case at all
as for the title
king george v the grandfather of queen
elizabeth
declared in the early 20th century quote
the grandchildren of the sons of any
such
sovereign in the direct male line
save only the eldest living son of the
eldest son of the prince of wales
shall have and enjoy in all occasions
the style and title enjoyed
by the children of dukes of this realm
in layman's terms what that means is
that
all the little boys in the direct mail
line from the
from the king will be styled
prince in the line of succession
harry is the son of
charles but harry is not
second in line to the throne or third in
line to the throne or fourth or fifth
he's sixth now in line to the throne
if william has more kids he'll be even
further away
archie far further away than that it
doesn't just go on like that
forever this is something that has been
a long-standing convention
no evidence whatsoever that it is racist
or bigoted
but everything in this world has to come
down to race and i think some of the
revulsion that people feel
at this absolutely sickening interview
between the markles mr and mrs markle
and oprah is this sick obsession with
race and this failure to have gratitude
for anything
that we have even if you're a rich
famous beautiful
princess or prince i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the michael knowles show
to check out the full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
you